[Music]
hello and welcome to another
night of chess on psychology
hopefully um we've been doing this for
almost two years now so you are all
caught up with every other thing we do i
think we just actually broke into the
hundred something video so you have a
hundred videos to go watch if you're not
caught up
a while back we did we kept doing an
opening series and people really liked
it and i know caleb did opening series
and people really liked it
um i wanted to do more like a world
championship series
you know like there's
at least
16 that we can talk about
excluding the women world champions but
um
so i did a few of those there's um
there's tall out there there's there's a
magnus june out there so
feel free to give those series a try but
we are kind of doing something a little
bit different anymore
we're gonna be doing
opening series and we're gonna be doing
uh with a more focus on sicilian as
whites so
um i am going to share some of my
personal favorite ways to play against
sicilian which some might argue is not
the best choice because you know
everybody would know what i play but
i just love you that much so giving you
all my personal stuff
so i'm showing you some of the personal
games that i've played
different tournaments over the years so
some of it is online some of it is in
person some of it was rated some of it
was
friendly so
it's a big mush
so um for
today we're going to be talking about
um
a kind of a sideline that's kind of
annoying a lot of people know it a lot
of people play it differently
and well that's okay we're going to
learn how to play against it
there is a different
video series that we've done about
maroxy bind that
you can find after
there will be a link
in the description or comments
and
if you want to know more about moroxy
that's the way to go um
in the next few weeks we'll be doing
night or delivers of dragon i have a
very painful gaming dragon woof
uh pause and con
and we're gonna take it from there
so but right now let's jump to it
um
let me actually close that part
so
also
um
this was a very i remember that's the
game that i'm going to show you first
was very interesting because i played
this uh
the the i'll have trouble saying the
last name but the first name paulina
she became like really strong after we
played this back this was back in 2015
we played in moscow open um she i think
is very close to becoming 2 500 now and
i know she's definitely in i am and she
was playing with the russians national
team uh in a very recent tournament so
but back then she was still pretty
strong but she was like the new newcomer
and i was already you know feeling like
a
hot shot but
anyways this was the game and i remember
because i had prepared so much for it
and it was still
not exactly as i wanted so
um exactly
people call this different names people
call it accelerated dragon it can turn
into
dragons can turn into
like marks the idea it just has like it
just can turn into so many different
things and i am a big fan of taking this
with the queen if my opponent gives me
the chance and we'll come back to it and
we'll talk about
some of the other options that are out
there what if black doesn't take it
what if um
white doesn't take with the queen so for
our purpose if we don't take with the
queen if you take with the knights
there's knight c6 and we can try to
turn it into maroxy there is a
possibility but we'll come back to that
later
so queen takes d4 knight f6
this is all theory
oh theory
and my opponent so paulina she played
knight to b6 right now which was very
lovely
uh
the
there's a question in the chat what if
they don't play g6 well g6 is what we're
talking about today because it's the
opening series about sicilian
g6 is what we're starting uh next week i
think we're gonna go with con slash
paulson
and the marx is already out there
um and i think we'll wrap it up with
dragon there'll be a nine different
between there too there's a lot of fun
stuff in sicilian
anyways so
uh knight b6 bishop of four again is
theory
you can start with knight c3 however
there is this uncomfortable
um
problem and then you would have to
retract the queen and then you would
have to deal with the
opponent's super active pieces and
you all know me i i hate it when my
opponent has active pieces and is happy
so even if it means i have an extra pawn
that's where i draw the line happy
opponents are not the type of opponents
i want
all right so
um i went for the bishop f4
there are a lot of controversies about
that
uh there is this d4 d5 sorry
and
take
then bishop f5 and again the pieces do
become relatively
annoying
from black side because black is like e5
and it's looking super cool
so be mindful of this if you choose to
play the way i did
be mindful that bishop ford does hold
this risk
in the chat saying that is not good for
beginner with a lot of typos this is a
very sharp line
well
that might be true
but
um i don't really have a target audience
i'm not doing a class for like super
beginner or super professional so i
believe anyone can learn as much as they
can from it
so let me know if you like it
uh jesus is a hyperx dragon analysis is
the excited dragon okay thank you thank
you for the distinction the only
difference is that g6 allows queen takes
d4 knight c6 allows
rose oh my god
rosa limo
i always read that as rosalindo i don't
know why in my head
ah not native english speaker we come up
with stuff of how things are pronounced
some of the joys of life
all right anyways let's look at this
game because this we're going to look at
something first and i want to be quick
about it
because i want to get to the other lines
too uh and thank you
um sin bad gp
all right
bishop g7
knight f3 logical
so we talked about how do
goodness
gracious that's a lot of fun
i
we talked about how
in knight b6 line this d5 could be a
little annoying so be mindful of that
bishop g7 was played
i went for knight c3
paulina went for d5
um
she could have also went for castle
and i would have gone for a long castle
and i was hoping to get into this
position actually
and then i could just go boom queen e3
hold everything together opponent
doesn't really have an attack but i do i
do have a pretty chill
oh was a chill i don't think this is
there's anything about this attack is
chilled
my rook is about to become completely
open their rook is not their knight is
just weird i have much better piece
activity so i i like this quite a lot
and this is actually winning now
this is what i was hoping for
but that did not happen unfortunately
um paulina went for d5
logical oh there's a question why not
ambassador
it's completely possible but i thought
it would give her more chances so i
decided to not go for it
and
take
i will on poisson now
if bishop takes c3 it is doable with the
bishop f5 idea again
but
i think point is still comfortable i
won't get that super cool attack that i
wanted anymore which is a little sad but
white is comfortable
uh paulie i went for bishop five first
gotta come back with the queen
i did have the choice of taking but i
wanted to avoid simplifying the position
this much
and um
i was still hopeful for
a different
side castle so i could start that attack
and that's actually what did happen in
the game with queen e2 castle castle
take
take beautiful quincy eight and now
first question
why to move what do you think we should
do
um
h3g4 ideas um
don't forget what your opponent might
want to do
whoa rook takes e6 with 95 ideas guys
our position is not that great to start
just throwing away pieces
i'm exp why just experiencing some
developmental problems because
i was slightly greedy and hungry and i
went then i ate a pond so
opponents might want to eat over here
they might want to do night before
they could want to do
create opportunities maybe like knight
a5 knight c4 so i don't have the luxury
of just doing a chill king b1 or chill a
h3
and word that's great advice i hope you
take it
so what else
ah
wait sinbad
i feel like that's a middle eastern name
but i just always it's not sin but i
always remember it as sandbot i don't
know if that's it yeah i don't know if
that's the same but anywho
um
that's
actually what i played in the game but
that was an inaccuracy
as white is so weird you gotta play
queen b5
and i say weird because i was just like
well what if they just take over here i
take back they try to exchange rooks
i don't wanna i don't wanna deal with
this
okay i do wanna actually deal with this
sorry i love this i wanna deal with this
this light i want
but um i didn't want to deal with double
pawns i didn't want to
deal with
my kingside and my king getting weak
some possible attacks
so i didn't want double pawns for the
sole purpose of not wanting double pawns
i went quindy too
and
opponent
could have punished me glad that she
didn't
but she could have punished me for this
inaccuracy now
what do you think is a good move for
black
technically this is no longer the
opening so if you feel like ah well we
wanted opening series
this is the sicilian middle game this is
how you how one could try to create an
attack
in the
c file
this is a very common sicilian ideas
night on c3 queen over here
so
what are some of the weaknesses in
white's position
ah the c4 square so if black could
somehow get some lights here without
getting eaten
yeah
night day five and it it kind of hurts
not gonna lie
it's just like ouch how do i defend this
like this is such a beautiful concept of
just pressure
knight a5 is looks like a weird move
because who puts the knight in a corner
while there's still stuff to develop
right
but that night a5 it's also funny
because it's
trying to trap my rook
gladly she didn't do it and i was very
very happy that she didn't she went for
night before
after night before i found the best move
what do you think is the best move
take your time
anytime
no this is a very hard position i was
playing this over the board classical
and my head was about to explode
um
matthias why not knight c4 uh if knight
c4 happened i would pick it up with my
bishop on f1 ah skaki you are right
hold on now
what do you think white wants
well well white wants to keep the pawn
and live happily ever after what did
what do you think black wants
what is the purpose of this knight
before
night before if not the immediate night
attack on queen
well we did the night before
ah there you go yes pressure on c2
that's what they want they want by pawn
sneaky
so i have to play knight d4 to defend it
uh-huh so after knight d4
opponent played knight c4 and i started
to feel that the pressure was lifting a
little because
now after knight c4
i can't easily take they take
and
this is totally cool
they helped me develop my bishop and get
rid of it
and they i don't feel as pressured
anymore i can play a3 i can take over
here
i have better options now so what do you
think right now would be uh more
annoying for
white
how do you think black could try to make
me uncomfortable
thank you very much
how can black make me uncomfortable um
mr z
i have no clue
i think black could try to go for
something like maybe rookie eight then i
would have to move this bishop like the
thing is okay what i'm looking at is if
black did this they would kind of win
this one tempo right because they got
rid of the bishop anyways
but it's this rookie a just like they
squeezed in a little like
tiny move in there anyways
so i think that would be a better choice
for them
um
all right so knight c4 take take and i
decided to just take this because this
bishop over here was just bothering me
and i didn't want to deal with it and i
was also kind of uh on
uncertain of how i would continue over
this
this just felt very uncomfortable
and i didn't
i didn't want to get myself into any
more uncomfortable situations
so i'd avoided it
and so i took over here they took
and i went for a very simple move of
bishop h6
my idea is simple if you want to be cute
about it i will take it and now i want
to give you beautiful checkmates
if you take i'll just come up
try to trap the night and i'm doing
checkmate ideas
right
so
um
now opponents has to be very careful
because i have some serious stuff going
on
what do you think
black should do right now
you know what i want to do as white
so how do you think black should try to
mess with that
and don't forget some ideas about checks
takes smoothie threats
i started giving this i thought of this
idea late last week and i started
telling my students and i got 40
students
so they i haven't had any complaints so
far so i'm gonna tell this idea to you
too
feel free to leave comments and share
your opinion i literally like spent less
than a week since i started giving out
this idea um
for some players who they keep repeating
the same mistakes
they might forget about diagonal checks
they might forget about forks they might
not
consider what the opponent wants to do
like you know like gosh darn it i have
this problem that i just keep doing and
doing and doing my recommendation was
well
why don't you leave a post-it whenever
you're doing puzzles leave a post it on
your
laptop and just have that
as a small like okay what am i supposed
to think
i also made the offer for like when
you're playing online but i also realize
that might have um unethical aspects so
don't
get too excited with this posted idea
but
for for improvement purposes if you're
playing like an unwrited game friendly
game and you want to
improve
and modify how you think having like a
piece of paper that you have your
problems on and you have to kind of go
over like scan for checks scan for takes
what does my opponents want some of
these some of these ideas
again this is like a very new idea that
i've had so if you have any questions
any thoughts on it please do let me know
in the comments i will come check
afterwards
yeah so that being said
right now what do you think my opponent
could do that would mess with my plan
f4 technically yeah technically it does
mess with it but i will still have a
pretty cool attack
even though i mean also i have an extra
pawn so i don't have any problem with
trying to exchange queens off and it
pick up even more material
now i'll be very happy with that too
um
so not f4 what about chicks
i don't think i saw this check idea
anywhere in the chat
so i see
all of you might have trouble with
thinking about checks so that that goes
in your upcoming post-its
all right so knight takes a2
i gotta take
they take
and now i really wish i could do this
queen g5 but it doesn't doesn't work
because they just take and i would have
to move and then this is a defender and
i i my rook is stuck
this doesn't work i wish it did
so i can't just go
uh play queen g5 whenever i want
um i kind of have a single move not to
get a worse position
what do you think this single move is
so why to move what do you think we
should do we're very close to wrapping
up this game so we can look at a
different line within this opening
um
well to be fair let me maybe start with
this if it's black to move what does
black want
let's start with that
okay i see the c3 idea being mentioned a
lot in the chat
all right so i'm assuming you are seeing
that black wants queen a1 check mate so
let's do c tree i'll save it i agree
paulina took i took
she went for f6 now
what do you think white should do in
this position
never play f6 that's funny um
don't forget now opponents might want to
check and pick this up
and this truck here is just
so
if rookie 7 check
king up boom bye
if king d2
check over here i don't want to give
that opportunity to my opponent
king c2 they can still give me check
and they can give me check
and they can give me even more check
king city not a bad idea but they have
opportunities and they can also grab
this file
so i went for rook d1
she went to rocky 8
and i played queen h5 that i'm
fine with not but not like super proud
of i feel like queen of four might have
been more in line with my current chess
philosophy
anyways queenish five they gave check i
went up
and they gave me a few checks
and i was trying to hide the king my
idea was if they give check again maybe
i could try to um
cover up they didn't paulina just went
for queen g4
and we traded and then we got into this
super
awesome end game so exciting
can't wait to have another beautiful end
game like this
and as you can imagine it's um
yeah it's kind of dead
yeah
it's just a very
very uncomfortable
uh
non-creative end game you just save your
pawns
you just try to avoid getting checkmated
and
you agree to a draw
so the game that i played i didn't draw
but it had lots of ups and downs
and
all right i'm going to go back to the
opening part of it
and we're going to talk about a whole
different okay maybe not the whole
difference but a difference line
what i want to talk about was
here knight b6 we talked about right
knight b6 is actually a very great idea
but there are other line
one of them notably being this e6
e6 is
how i say it nicely
just weird
just purely weird as black
be aware of the beauties that you're
gifting to your opponents
you shouldn't you should not make your
opponent feel that
cool about
their position like you shouldn't have
g6 and e6
and have the d6 and f6 square just
up in the air
so having said that
there are positions in which that is
acceptable
this is not one of it
so if you were to play e6 um there are
chances of me playing c4
and if not b4 then i can try to chase
that away
literally
because now if i take you can take here
but then i can also play nice c3 just
completely ignoring this knight and i
just want to
uh bring my knight this is already like
plus 3 for white
so yeah
but that's not what um
i did and also if i played c4 i would i
think opponents would have went back
instead of like b4 but hey you never
know
so c4 is actually what i would recommend
i went for a3 because i just wanted to
see what they would do
i wanted to just wait i wanted to do a
simple move before i decide what to
develop where to go what to push what
not to push you know all that chaotic
stuff
opponents on bishop g7 all right now
push
and i just decided to try to go for
development
they're also trying to develop and
protect this square so i can't easily
access their d6
knight c3
and i developed
and
all right
i continued with
my plan to do short castle i did have
some hopes for maybe someday i could try
to create an attack but my biggest hope
was
these two squares so just keep that in
mind they castled i castled
um
i was playing a tournament in um
switzerland called martini open back in
2015. if i'm not wrong i actually won
like the best woman prize for that and i
wasn't top 10 and i really liked it
so if anybody from switzerland or
martini here i like switzerland
anyways uh so this was a tournament
there
and for the life of me i can't remember
the round of it i know it was a morning
because i was very
sleepy
i'm not
the best morning person
anyways
um
c3 idea 92 c4 that's also possible
that's also a possibility that i see
in the chat now let's say opponents
enter f5
how do we like that
is that going like a ha
or ouch
because if they can actually cover up
they're doing fine
so is that a genius or a blender
and um
there's a question about uh what else
are these lectures aimed at i try to not
go for like a super beginner or super
hard thing so as long as you are fine
with the coordinates you should be able
to learn
something from it
some people enjoy
the specific opening some people prefer
to focus on the middle game so it's
completely up to you what you get out of
it
i don't really have a specific aim at it
i would say
actually i'm not gonna
the same way i didn't say it in my book
what's the
aloe aimed at i'm not gonna do it here
oh speaking of my book let me actually
show you the mug
i like this mug
it's a very beautiful mug
right
i wish my cat was on it though anyways
that's that's discussion for a
different time
it is a blender yes thank you
thank you chat people
it is a blender um
and i wish i had my evil laughter button
right now that would be cool but yeah
with not just on poisson but discovery
attack too
yes exactly
they take back i just picked that up and
i i remember opponent's face going what
and they just played another move and
then they resigned i decided to just
take that too for the fun of it
i mean i was gonna lose the bishop
anyways might as well grab a pawn
yeah and then they just he just resigned
so
what i was hoping to show you
with this e6 line was a very simple
don't do it or if your opponent does it
be happy smile because they're giving
you permanent
outposts all right now let's switch the
gears and talk about a different line
knight c7 i have a few games in knight
c7 so let's try to see how much we can
get to
before we get too deep in 97 i just want
to briefly mention this knight before
idea because it's such an old line and i
remember when i first learned this they
were telling me be careful there is this
line that's now your if it's like uh if
you play it wrong and you play like
knight c3 this is losing
now i want to ask your opinion why do
you think white is losing now
what were the first few move e4 c5
knight f3 g6 d4 take queen takes
knight f6 e5 knight c6
queen
a4 knight d5 queen e4 now knight b4
exactly
chat got it
let me see anybody in person wanna
give it a try
yeah
yep
beautiful
d5 the problem is d5 even if you do the
beautiful on poisson
right
yep
i agree
so
for that reason opponent wants to play
d5
how do we stop it
how do we interfere with that
bishop c4
not exactly an interference
per se
they would still play d5 you do on
poisson they'll still play bishop f5
i'm enjoying this
c5
g4 is tricky jesus how did it land on g4
i was thinking a3 would be in
suggestions but i guess not knight a3
okay i can
see how that might be appealing
ah there we go thank you elijah
yes bishop e5 beautiful
now if d5 what do we do
take who
take who
we like pins
because of the pressure and the mental
pressure
this is a beautiful pen how do we use it
come on you got this
you're good to look for checks
but if not checks exactly yes
i'm not going to stand in the way of my
queen's happiness yes
beautiful nights
so bishop b5 is like kind of a trap like
hey you want to play d5
yes and then you get the knight
i like traps anyways
uh queen a5 should be played and there's
knight c3 and then there's d5 and then
take and then goes there and then you
come up here
it's a mess but the point being
you get the rook well technically so
today
but this is actually
winning for white
okay maybe not winning advantageous for
white let's be very careful with my word
choice so
the point of it being if you do play
third move queen takes d4 this is the
only line that you need to have
memorized literally memorized there's no
there's like understanding to it too but
the memorization part of it is very
important because you might know that
yeah here my opponent wants to play d5
and bishop f5 but if you don't remember
bishop b5 then
well you're
not gonna be very happy let me put it
that way so um
you gotta remember a little
you gotta remember but to be fair not
many people actually play this as black
so they're dds2 back in like 10 years
ago
but
anyways
uh
jacob and sebastian yes but it's very
important to just be aware of this
opening
and the only line that you need to
memorize if you do decide to play this
queen takes d4
you gotta have this move sequence
memorized
i would be very happy if you also
understand it but even if you don't
understand it you gotta have it
memorized like this is you got to have
this memorize i will i can emphasize
more on it if you want but
anyways
okay bishop before
bishop out
and this is the game that i played with
polina we talked about e6 and we talked
about
knight b4 now let's go and talk about
knight c7 for a little bit
all right so knight c7
do you think we should do
are we worried about anything specific
thank you father yes i do
so
bishop e3 possible
but
opponent doesn't really have any like
super threats going on
yeah so black might want to do knight e6
that's true
um
what else do you think your bishop
belongs on e3
do you think your knight belongs on c3
what do you think your pieces belong
i am big fan of this knight c3
let's say opponent goes bishop g7
what would we do
oh is h4 an idea here
um
kinda
possibly i have other things that i
would like to be able to do before
i would attend to h4
maybe let's try to figure out which side
are we trying to castle
okay i'm getting more bishop and fours
uh-huh
that's what i went for two
i went from bishop f4 as well
um
the other possibility would be bishop c4
and if like b5 then you have bishop d3
and i wasn't the biggest fan of that
i played it it was a little
uncomfortable
okay i won the game
what to do
i'm kidding um i did win the game though
because there is a small beautiful
tactic here well actually i think bishop
b4 is better but anyways
uh just to mention bishop c4 is doable
but um
we don't necessarily want to mix and
match too much
so bishop f4 i'm a bigger fan of bishop
iv
if opponent goes b6 we have long castle
we'll come back to it in a second if
opponent was knight to e6 we could just
castle or we could just you know move
the bishop away
um
if
let's say not bishop f4
wait sorry not knight t6 what if d5
is that doable now or is that just a
beautiful beautiful blunder
uh i think that's
there are both kingside castle and
queenside castle is doable
uh so i think it's ultimately up to you
to make that decision
was taking e5 a threat
not just yet
but i don't want to
deal with this on fine position before i
mentioned before exactly prevents d5 you
just pick up a pawn
right all right perfect
um
so bishop f4
and my opponents went for b6
okay as we just mentioned there are
other options like knight e6 or bishop
or pawn okay like i guess pawn d5 is not
exactly an option
but they can do it i would like it but i
don't i'm not too hopeful so if they
play b6 we can castle
and now this can become slightly
uncomfortable
so i just went for what i thought was
logical
with queen e1 and this was a tournament
if i'm not mistaken it's been
oh my god eight years old
like he played this game eight years ago
oh
um
this was a game that i played in
the first time i played the world
junior championship
i was 15 so back in 2013
and um
lovely all right so
ah
okay
getting nostalgic
what if knight e6
what do you do
do you want to eat your bishop well
they would like to exchange the bishop
so yeah let's bring it let's not let's
try to exchange it
our way
rather than um
knight takes bishop queen takes bishop
and this other bishop still stays on the
board so take take and now opponent
actually went for queen b8 i was a
little skeptical on this
and i chose to play queen e3 which i
kind of regret kind of not too much
but what do you think is a good idea for
whites now i had trouble coming up with
what's what to do right now because i
knew that my position was better
because upon ching is on castle i have
better space
you know more open files better
developments but the how to make it work
how to
um
convert that advantage
was really hard for me so converting
advantage that's a very very important
thing i've been thinking for a while to
do a lecture about it but i um
i'm kind of doing series right now and i
was doing serious before that but
anyways
that idea of converting advantage
growing up i had trouble
looking for it and understanding it as
well so
if you have any
resources on converting advantage please
leave it in the comments and help others
too
all right um
oh something about bishop g something
about knight g4 bishop g4
bishop c4 good god
take control of d5 square since uh it's
okay that's possible
95
i guess possible well the thing is this
guy is under attack
so opponent might want to take it
so i think the reason i came back with
my queen was that
ah thank you father that deb 22.83 is
the best i know right i i played such
amazing engine moves when i was 15.
okay
kidding i mean
here and there um but i i was
considering maybe bishop b5 might have
been more interesting
because if a6 then i could just get rid
of that knight
and then do knight d5 but at the same
time i don't think i would be more
comfortable with this because who is
going to kick this night away
and yes technically i am attacking that
but i also helped opponents get rid of
some of those uncomfortable pieces that
they had
so
yeah
it's a possibility
but um definitely a possibility
but i don't think um
it might have been
the trickiest way to play it so
uh queen b8 i went for queen e3
which according to engine is the best
one of course why not
and so opponents went through queen c8
that was a wrong move queen c8 too chill
now i made a mistake i should have
actually started to push over here i
didn't i was young and naive and
i didn't push enough anyways
i was actually young and naive and
didn't push enough
that's not
untrue all right after queen c8
i won bishop c4 i just wanted to develop
and bishop c4 looked like a good
development but it wasn't the move that
my position needed my bishop on c4 i was
never truly going to you know gain
anything out of it so why did i put my
bishop on c4
just because it looks good it's not
reason enough it doesn't really have a
purpose however if i started pushing
this pawn now i would have a purpose i
could start opening up
some weaknesses on opponent's king open
up some files on opponents king actually
start to make them more uncomfortable if
they play h5 okay now i could go bishop
b5
i could start to bring pressure
but i didn't and
oh an
interesting idea that's um it's
mentioned in the chat that black could
want to do long castle totally yeah
possible so i went for bishop c4 day one
night day four and then i got to move
the bishop again then they proposed a
bishop exchange and then i had to try to
defend the bishop and they did the
bishop exchange and then they changed
the knights and you see within a matter
of few moves the position just changed
so much
and now opponents pieces have more
flexibility
more possible threats
and okay i defended
and they are trying to attack again
they just started gaining tempo after
tempo and i did not like that
again proposing to exchange queens and
it's uncomfortable because opponents
king is in the middle of the board they
shouldn't be doing this right
but they did
and um
this game ended up
it's still comfortable for me but
it's not that big of a deal anymore and
um we tried to repeat a little and then
we tried to give it another look and i
was still fine there was no sacrifice
unfortunately but it wouldn't have
worked
and so i started to want to
push more
i tried i still have advantage i feel
like if i was playing this now when i'm
more experienced and i've dealt with
more um
like tiny better positions but still
uncomfortable i would have been able to
win it but in that game um she was like
200 points more and i
ended up just being like yeah let's just
accept draw
did i regret it
not too much because i was
i did my best but anyways um
yeah like i had i had advantage like
here i should have possibly taken this
and then try to
enjoy the open files
anyways that's a whole different end
game topic but something that would have
been possible
but we repeated they agreed to a draw
all right
um i would like to actually mention
something else
different line
if you're up for it
so
wait wait wait ah here
we talked about knight away knight away
knight over here and e6 right so i'm
gonna switch gears go back back back
back back
and talk about knight takes d4 because
some people do play knight takes d4 so
for knight takes d4 um the most thing
that i've encountered is either knight
c6 or bishop g7 if bishop g7 i'm kind of
fond of c4 to just try to transpose it
to
maroxy which there should be a link
there soon there
some sometime
soon future
because we did the marxy bind last year
and so c4 would be interesting and then
you're going to do the moroxi style
stuff
short cast out so rook and c1
and
we'll do that we'll talk about that very
briefly later and please do watch the
video for that that's like two hours of
video all right
so uh there's knight c6 which you can
still technically go for c4 and i think
you should still be fine with
um
during the first the during the knight
c6 idea i actually went for bishop e3 in
one of my games knight f6 then i went
for knight c3 and then i was like oh
oh oh this just turned into
some weird
uncomfortable dragon that i don't play i
got tricked into it again this is like
years ago i was young and naive and all
those stuff but i got tricked into a
line that i didn't want to get trimmed
to
i didn't want to go for
dragon but i ended up in a dragon
without d6 so my opponent can just do d5
oh yeah it was uncomfortable
i tried to like avoid d5 but
this knight on b3 with short castle is
just like
if my pawn was on c4 now we're talking
this would be my roxy i would like that
but it doesn't really work
yeah i tried my best okay i retract my
comments
i tried the best i could
this is not my best what is this h3 what
was i thinking
anyways uh what was i thinking oh i
won't look at this game don't do this
don't make all these beautiful
weaknesses for your squares ooh i need
to go back in time and have a talk with
my 8 years back self
okay
uh if not knight b3 there was another
option obviously of simple castle
and then if point a5 you still have
knight b3 of course there's nothing
fundamentally wrong about playing
this opening but if you do play it make
sure you're comfortable with your
opponent
not playing d6 because the whole idea
about go back back back back back
this g6 is to be a little
tricky
about
if the knight takes then ha ha i didn't
have to play d6 to get you into dragon
so
just be aware of what you're getting
yourself into
all right so um
there's that
the other thing take take
was oh
okay one final line that i wanted to
talk about was this bishop g7
now uh
it's possible elijah that i tried to try
to be like
cool with my
pawns and transposition and it didn't
work
uh thank you great wolf thank you for
the kind words
all right so bishop g7 you can
definitely go for c4
and if knight c6 again if take take you
got my roxy check out the video for that
if not take
if you do knight c6 now you can take
check bishop d2
take knight c3 the idea is
i want to simply enjoy my beautiful pawn
structure and if you try to mess with it
you might probably do this i'll just
play h3 castle castle bishop out i can
just go rough c1 i can also go like
knight d5
and uh this is like again like this
moroxy bind structure-ish with a weird
queen out here so i'm not complaining
i can maybe do a small queen hunt
anyways um that's another thing that i
wanted to mention about
how to try to get another moroxy bind
idea
and finally
wait a second need to scroll down
ah yes what if you decide to take
i personally choose c4 because
i have a better experience in rfc
watch my video for that
um but what if you choose to take that
is again totally doable
you just have to know the theory behind
it because your opponent could give you
a check
and after this check and i c3 is
interesting c3 is doable but c3 they can
take
and then you gotta do like some weird
knight e3 bishop d3 it gets too chill
um what i would what i play that i kind
of liked was this knight c3
if you do knight f6
i can play e5
if you play queen take c5 i can play
knight d5
knight f6 where there is a beautiful
queen trap coming up
if queen c6 there's bishop b5 right
af queen d6 beautiful bishop deep bishop
f4 where can the queen go
this is actually kind of cool my
opponents just like this was actually a
real game that i played but they're
lower rated but still it was kind of fun
then they resigned after this
obviously i mean there's a missing queen
there that can't be can't be found
anywho uh let's go back so the queen c5
is
relatively uncomfortable because of
knight d5 and then opponents would have
to go like knight ec knight a6 or e6 or
queen a5 oh there was a i think there
were like a 1600 federated at that point
i have no idea what they what their
rating is now
but um
this is like some of the ideas are
either knight a6 or e6 or queen a5 to
try to avoid this upcoming b4 idea
so as long as black those does those
they're not completely
busted so if you're watching this and
you're like okay queen c5 i love it be
mindful that there is knight d5
beautiful before idea beautiful but your
friends can you know just
move it
away now are you better yeah you have
better development you don't even lose
anything so
enjoy that
um
and in the game that i had that i still
wish i won that's one of those small
games that still hurts here and there i
was playing in world junior championship
the second time i played so in 2015
i was playing i was 17 at that point i
was playing in hunting monsters i played
so beautifully
i was very close to scoring a medal and
i didn't hurt still
but
this game it ended in a draw i know i
had advantage only with half a point
difference
i would have because i ended up in sixth
place
so it would have been much i was so
close to that beautiful
world championship junior medal
okay not the gold but i did beat the
girl who got gold
anyways
um so i was playing from with a girl
from armenia
uh i
i remember her susanna
trouble with last names but i think this
one is um gaboyan i saw sarah on
instagram here and there she seems to be
happy
anyways um she played this knight f6 i
went for e5 she tried to continue with
the knight
i tried to be as aggressive as possible
it was like aggressive game like boom
and then another like felt like a small
boxing match at this point
i feel like b5 would have been funny but
i didn't um
actually b5 would have been smart not
funny if you want knight c6 uh-uh you're
not cutting 96 today
i think it would have actually been
genius
anyways i went for queen e4 they went
knight c6 bishop before d6 bishop to
five and we just kind of
it somehow was fine i don't understand
how this was i mean i understand how
this was fine but like i couldn't
believe my eyes like how is this
position fine for black
black is totally fine
i try to create some ideas
and
it kind of worked but not really and
then it was such a big mess
and anyways the game ended a draw after
like
30-something moves from here
but um i did want to mention this knight
f6 opening as well
so a small recap today we looked at
this idea d4 take we take it queen if
not take what we just talked about you
have two different options take
or c4
you have other options too such as
knight c3 but just be mindful of that
accelerated dragon stuff
or hyper accelerated dragon stuff
there is going to be a miracle link that
we did from last year in the chat well
description thank you
and uh i did have some questions from
you
uh that you're more than welcome to
answer in comments i'll do my best to
check it out here and there
and um
if the if you have any particularly cool
game of this line that you played
make sure to join us in twitch
this week or next week pretty much all
wednesdays
right after this class we have a small
switch to twitch we're gonna analyze
your games so
um
yeah with that
i'm actually gonna say please buy my
book and let me know how you like it
i have to do it
and
with that i will see you shortly on
twitch good day
[Music]
you